anti-israel and anti-American protests
exploding across the mid East the Arab
world whipped up in a frenzy over the
Gaza Hospital explosion protests have
been raging outside the US Embassy in
Beirut Lebanon the chaotic scenes
featured water cannons tear gas even
fires Mike Tobin is in southern Israel
with more on that
Mike and Jesse as air strikes and
artillery continue into the Gaza Strip
an explosion behind a hospital in Gaza
sent shock waves around the world as you
mentioned the Lebanese Armed Forces uh
needed to use water cannons and tear gas
to control the crowd uh that was
demonstrating outside of the US Embassy
in Beirut they even threw rocks and
other projectiles at the uh at the
embassy Aman Jordan anti-israel protests
turned violence as they did in Iraq in
Iran state sponsored protesters marched
down the street chanting death to Israel
death to America security video supports
Israel's claims that it was Palestinian
Islamic Jihad that fired a barrage of
rockets resulting in the explosion
behind the hospital the uh you hear some
artillery in the background the video
shows uh Rockets firing in the direction
of Israel one goes off course resulting
in an explosion on the ground meantime
after President Biden left Israel prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu assembled
his War cabinet in the Kira Israel's
version of the Pentagon meantime the
artillery bangs away into the night tens
of thousands of troops are at the ready
waiting for their orders to enter the
Gaza Strip Jesse thanks Mike so Dana
you're seeing a lot of uh attacks
against embassies not just American
embassies there was a French Embassy an
Israeli Embassy do you see this
spreading throughout the evening I well
part of the thing right before the
commercial break when I said that Iran
reportedly is running TV ads recruiting
this is their work progress
administration rather this is how they
give people jobs is to to basically
protest or to hire them in order to go
and and be ready for this fight there is
as I've been listening to a lot of
different uh people today a lot of
concern about a second front with
Hezbollah but also I got a warning today
from somebody that we really need to pay
attention to what's happening in Iraq
ctib Hezbollah is there in Iraq and
targeting our Embassy and our troops
there so it could possibly be that this
they try to draw Us in absolutely even
more than we already are but also all of
Western all the Western world that's why
you had the Coalition of the Willing
Coalition of the Willing wasn't just
because they were like yeah let's go we
really want to fight it's because they
understood that we faced an existential
threat from radical Islamic terrorism
that was just clear as day the moral
Clarity on that was not in question
everybody called the White House on that
day and said we are with you because we
realize what we're up against and then
we got farther away from September 11th
we got back into a September 10th
mindset and now here here we are again
but we are in a better position in order
to fight back against it than we were
it's just that everybody has to Gear Up
we've got this conflict in Russia with
ukra Ukraine with the Russians we have
the possibility of problems with China
we have problems with coup attempts in
Africa which also where is where you
have radical Islamic terrorism breeding
so yes I that's all to say I think
there's a heightened awareness and I
think the president perhaps will try to
address that tomorrow night in his prime
time address mhm and I believe mad the
Israeli intelligence agency is probably
sharing intelligence with the Central
Intelligence Agency about all these
Rising threats against the embassies and
that's Greg that's one of the main
reasons or a reason why we're so tight
with Israel I haven't checked my sources
on that Jesse but I'll get back to you
all of this is going according to
hamas's strategy and plan right and the
media right now is their PR arm again
the the hospital attack was the was the
spark that was need needed to justify
these Pro protests uh I don't think the
demonstrations should matter one bit
right you need to step back because
we're right now we're we're kind of
micro watching every event every day
something happens something happens
something happens uh we need to step
back from this because the decision has
been made a course has been made you got
to accept it now you got to look ahead
what worked before the Abraham Accords
that worked and you know it worked
because the forces against peace
initialize its attack for that reason
and so what comes after this for your
own uh sense of peace and and and and
you know just your mental stability
think about what comes after you know
it's a Cooperative Alliance of Arab
Nations right to assume responsibility
over the region with Israel providing
security a really capable president
would be working on that right now but
we also need to look at at this
situation and use it to predict what
might happen in our future you know are
there seeds of this lineage conflict
Brewing I've said it there is phrases
like white privilege and colonizer are
the currency of of shaming and targeting
based on lineage okay and we need to be
persuasive in showing how mistaken this
ideology is because it's here right now
I can feel it you've seen it in Times
Square you've seen it on these campuses
judge Janine you know the uh
the thing about Hezbollah and the thing
about what's going on in Lebanon really
concerns me because whereas Hamas has
these homemade missiles you know they
they take things that we give them or
that Israel gives them for humanitarian
reasons and they try to make these bombs
you're talking about a very skilled
military with Hezbollah they are trained
well they have very Precision made
missiles uh you're talking about a
serious serious situation if that if
that front opens up and what you've got
is Iran who is now testing the resolve
of Israel uh to see you know how how
hard they're going to fight and whether
or not they need to get involved and the
West Bank right now uh Samaria and Judea
are very important because if if they
start fighting and it starts getting hot
in the West Bank then the then the
message there is we're all getting
involved it's hot enough now in Israel
and um a friend of mine who was high up
in the IDF said to me you know what this
is not uh 67 this is not 73 this is
1948 this is uh the existential threat
that we face and you've got this axis of
authoritarianism you've got Iran you've
got Russia you've got China and they
know that they're in the fight of their
life and Russia and China probably
benefiting from a lot of the world's
attention now off of them without
question uh um I agree with the I agree
with the judge I think one of the
reasons that President Biden uh has has
it's a part I think Dana open uh at the
outset of the show has been giving uh
advice to to show some restrain and
that's be strategic about the response
uh is that he understands exactly what
the what the judge just said Hezbollah
is a far more sophisticated uh fighting
force with greater resources more more
missiles that are more sophisticated uh
and what we don't want is an escalation
but I think with the president's
presence strongly strongly suggested is
if this is where you want to go we are
standing with Israel and we will be
prepared uh for whatever whatever you
whatever you decide to do but it would
be in your best interest not to do that
okay well hopefully the Hamas doesn't
get their hands on the hund million Doll
Joe Biden's giving them hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else